hey youtuberverse coming up star talk
cosmic queries
a look at 30 years of the hubble space
telescope
this is star talk i'm your host neil
degrasse tyson your personal
astrophysicist and i got with me chuck
knight jeff yes chuck in the house
neil all right this is a cosmic queries
edition
absolutely and we're celebrating 30
years of the hubble space telescope wow
yeah
30 was launched in 1990 april look at
that
yeah and we're talking across someone
right here i know he's so rude of us
very rude of us edwin would be ashamed
so so we have jennifer weisman jennifer
welcome thank you
i think it's your first time visiting
it's wonderful to be you know we go way
back but your first time
yeah it's long overdue and i got your
pedigree here senior project scientist
for the hubble space telescope
at the nasa goddard um uh
what's the full space flight center we
have a goddard here
we have a guy for space studies yeah we
have got our institute for
space got her got around got her yeah
so the goddard space flight center
in greenbelt maryland correct right
outside of washington dc
and you're primarily responsible for um
making sure hubble is as scientifically
productive
as possible wow and sure enough
that's what it has been we're going to
get into that yeah there's a lot of
professionally what would you say is
your special your cosmic specialty
i'm interested in how stars continue to
form in interstellar clouds
so pictures from hubble where stuff with
the clouds yes
that's her nice well that's not all she
took him personally
uh not exactly she owns them all right
she owns all those
uh this is called inflation in some way
no there are people
all over the world studying different
aspects of how stars and planetary
systems around them presumably
are continuing to form
but it's you're in the in the right
place to to be fed
absolutely we're just uh we're we're
blessed to be fed with all this new
information from the hubble space
telescope
and also telescopes uh all kinds of
other telescopes in space and on the
ground we use them all
together in complementary fashion so you
kind of layer the information to put it
together and get a
dare i say it a better picture exactly
i think of it like a symphony orchestra
the conductor is pulling out some
parts of the music from the trumpets and
some from the percussion and some from
the violins and so forth but
all together it gives you the full piece
of music so astronomers use some
information from
the hubble space telescope some from
other space telescopes some from
telescopes on the ground
they all have some different niche you
know they get some different
colors or parts of the wavelength
spectrum or a different types of fields
of view
and precision and we use all that
together to answer the questions we have
about
galaxies or stars or planets or whatever
we're interested in
so tell me you don't just happen to be
at the goddard
space flight center that's where hubble
is controlled
the hubble uh space telescope control
room is yes
at the nasa goddard space flight center
then what's that
hubble building on the campus of johns
hopkins
at johns hopkins we have the space
telescope science
institute which is a wonderful place
with hundreds of
scientists and other specialists who
work with us at goddard to help us
manage the daily science operations of
hubble
to help with the selections of which
proposals that are sent in from around
the world
actually get the time on the hubble
telescope i don't think people think
much about that
yeah the data just show up right right
but somebody somebody had to do an
american idol version of
yo i need hubble that's the next big
show coming to fox
yo i need help show me your proposal
right right
that's a really good analogy but it's
not done
quite the way it's done in terms of the
tv shows what's done is that scientists
around the world will write a written
proposal
for why they want to use the hubble
space telescope why
are the observations they want to do so
important to advanced science
and why do they need the hubble space
telescope to do that okay as opposed to
any other exactly
right right because you don't want you
don't want to waste
i think this is true for the allocation
committee they're not going to give you
time
for a proposal that you could do on a
ground-based telescope
because space based telescopes is so
expensive and so precious
every moment of observing time exactly
yeah so you have to make the case
why is it important that we use this
precious time with the hubble telescope
to observe this particular galaxy or
this particular exoplanetary system
and why do we need the hubble telescope
or the particular instruments that are
on hubble
to do that and that goes through a
pretty stringent peer review process we
have specialists come in
and review all the proposals and rank
them
and in the end basically one and four or
one in five
get uh time on the hubble space
telescope what's it like on american
idol is it one in five
i'm pretty i think a a little bit
less than that so you're better off
applying for hubble time yeah
actually yeah you probably are probably
not to be honest
although i should add that we're pretty
good about
storing this data so once the
observations are done with hubble the
the data are put in an archive that's
easily accessible
and so scientists around the world often
go into that archive pull out data
that's already there
but they can use it for something else
and in fact about half of the
results the peer-reviewed published
science discoveries and results coming
from hubble now
are based on data that scientists have
taken out of that archive
so if you if you use this the telescope
then everything that you glean from
using it is now open source god's better
than that i think is it better no no no
because it's i had my own motives
right for observing that part of the sky
right yeah
but maybe you have another thing you
could
extract from the data that i haven't
thought of yet right
that's right exactly that's right but
there is nothing proprietary
well there is for some types of
observations
see now that's all i care about is who
gets to who gets the proprietary stuff
there are some types of proposals where
the proposing team get a few months
yeah mike this is my cluster right now
no
nobody owns anything in the universe
uh personally but uh yeah but some of
the some of the proposals the proposing
team gets a few months of time to do
what they actually propose to do and do
it well because we want them to have the
time to do it
well okay and then the data gets put in
this archive and then it's open to
everyone okay and so and there are other
types of observations that are
generally done like big surveys and
things that the
let's say the director of the space
telescope science institute decides
would be a good general purpose use of
hubble
and that data immediately goes into
public
uh purview so so it can be immediately
used by scientists around the world but
anybody in the public can reach the
archive
we also have an image gallery that i
think is probably of more interest to
most general
people in the in the science interested
public and that
you can find at uh our websites nasa.gov
hubble or hubblecite.org but these have
the images the things that you really
think about when you think of hubble's
galaxies or
desktops
that's where you go and that's just all
free to anyone around the world to use
and enjoy
and that's something i'm very proud of
about the hubble mission is that we've
made
all of this data and all of these images
free for anyone around the world
hates you well it's uh it's inspiring
to everyone no it is and we thank you
for it before we get to the questions i
got one more
um one more inquiry here
the i don't think the public knows that
there's some allocation of time
that i mean you hinted at it but i want
to hear more
so is it still true that the director
can just say
here's a good idea everyone will benefit
let's just do this it's not going
through the telescope allocation
committee okay so it's a
director's discretionary time does that
still exist it does
so the director of the space telescope
science institute who currently is dr
kenneth sembach can has a certain
allocation of
of time with hubble each year that
they can use for what they think is the
most
some scientific purpose that might not
come through
sort of the general competitive process
with with scientists around the world
and usually this time
is done is used for let's say a kind of
big
survey or a general purpose observation
that will be of use
to people for many years to come uh
could could it be used for something
that's a little quirky
a little let me tell you that would that
that would be a little quirky
you would have to have a great deal of
trust in that director
you know well that's what when you want
to believe that there are
aliens in ngc 38 or what
i'm positive all right
well let me assure you that we take
great care in choosing the directors of
the space telescope science institute we
have
excellent ones i'm going to reference so
i'll mention a couple of these that i
think are
particularly noteworthy they're not
political appointees
right right the the current uh institute
space telescope science institute
director dr ken simbach has very wisely
allocated directors discretionary time
to do
a lot of observations in the ultraviolet
part of the spectrum
looking at stars and star forming
regions that that radiate light in this
high
energy frequency range well why is that
well that's because hubble
is really the only general purpose
telescope right now that can see
in the ultraviolet and you have to be
above the earth's atmosphere to see in
the ultraviolet because of the filtering
effects of the atmosphere unless you're
jordi laforge
well exactly but this is this is
important to get this data
and get it in the archive while we can
and then we can use it for many years to
come
there's another director's discretionary
project that i think is really
noteworthy and this came from years ago
a previous director dr bob williams
used his director's discretionary time
to just point off
in a direction of space where there
weren't very many nearby stars to drown
out the image and just collected light
from many ways
crazy pointing to nowhere
listen that's pretty dark over there
yeah yeah let's put this away
there's nothing interesting some people
did push back on this and said this is a
very valuable time on this telescope
there it's a lot of competition why
would you
quote unquote waste your director's
discretionary time this way
because i'm the director there you go
but
basically it was uh you know let's look
and see we think there are probably some
faint galaxies that will pick up by
just integrating light receiving light
for for days
but we weren't sure after several days
of doing this
the result was this image that's now
iconic it contains thousands of little
smudges of light they are all galaxies
it's called the hubble deep field and
we've done some subsequent ones called
like the ultra deep
it's one of the most famous images it's
certainly from hubble
and it's my favorite yeah but it really
showed us
visually what we may have suspected
already just from the
the physics and the in the the
cosmological theories but that our
universe is filled with galaxies
and they come in many different shapes
and sizes
and of course the intriguing thing about
getting these feels is that you're
seeing all these galaxies in one picture
but of course the ones that are
actually farther away you're seeing them
as they were farther back in time
so if you can somehow tease out which of
those galaxies are closer to us and
which of them and that image are farther
away
and compare their their differences are
they different in their morphology are
they different
in composition sometimes you need other
telescopes to get that information
why does this one look like a sombrero
you can see how galaxies have changed
over time so it's a true time machine
that you can now see visually and hubble
really set the foundation for this kind
of
pictorial study of galaxy evolution
and and i think it's just a wonderful
accomplishment that but that was based
on
a a very wise um but brave use of
directors discretionary time with the
hubble space store
all along yeah and also once the hubble
sort of
pitches tent right there right other
telescopes can say
i can now get different kind of
information from that saying the same
thing let me go to the same place
wow so it's probably one of the most
observed spots on the sky today
it is so we now have deep we have other
positions on the sky also that have been
observed in these kind of deep field
ways using
different kinds of telescopes like the
chandra x-ray observatory
or one of neil's favorite telescopes on
the ground and all of these telescopes
have
different capabilities and so they
complement hubble and are giving us
a tremendous understanding of how the
universe has changed over time yeah
there you go
that's really cool all right very very
let's go to some i don't know how much
time we have in this segment i don't
know how much time we have
in this couple times let's do it hey all
right patreon members first
yes we do a patreon member first paying
fans get their questions first okay they
support us on patreon
yes quite frankly we're easily bought
thank you
this message brought to you by chuck
knight from star talk radio
anyway uh this is sheri lynn sk uh
she says dr tyson dr weissman and uh hey
chuck
that's not what she said no
yes as he goes what are two or three
discoveries that laypersons
like myself can reference when talking
to others about the fantastic
contributions
hubble has given us right now all i can
say is
it took some really pretty pictures of
some stuff and i need
better ammo for those of us not literate
in
astrophysics questions that's a lovely
question right
yeah rank the science how would you put
that well i'm not going to
rank uh rank order because there's a lot
of just between us
no one else has to know but i would say
there are some profound
uh discoveries in in different realms of
astrophysics that hubble has
really made a a a groundbreaking if you
will or space breaking if you will a
contribution
i like to change
one of the first things hubble did was
to confirm that there
are in fact supermassive black holes
in the cores of galaxies there were
it was theorized that that was the case
perhaps but
one of the first observations hubble did
was to
look at the core of another galaxy
m87 for example is is one of these other
galaxies that we knew was kind of active
we could see that there was like a
high-speed jet coming out of the core
but we weren't sure what was
causing these these types of things
hubble looked at another external galaxy
and saw that the gas
moving around the core of that galaxy
was moving very fast
and so when you have something orbiting
very fast but you don't know what it's
orbiting you can pretty easily calculate
what the mass of that
material is based on the distance from
the core that the the material is moving
and its velocity and the only thing that
could be that massive
in such a small volume had to be a super
massive black hole
so hubble then became what we call our
supermassive black hole finder because
with subsequent instruments on hubble we
actually
looked at the cores of lots of other uh
galaxies and confirmed over and over
again that supermassive black holes are
often if not always perhaps in the cores
of galaxies
so what what went un implied but not
stated there is
you needed hubble to do that because
hubble has very high resolution
exactly right other telescopes it's just
a smudge and you can't find something so
close to
a tiny center exactly yeah that's that's
a point that needs to be made the reason
hubble is there at all is because we put
it above the atmosphere the atmosphere
has a blurring effect on
light coming through and it even filters
out some types of light
so hubble being above the atmosphere
gives us very high resolution
observation
exactly and that's why we were able to
use hubble to just
to discern this gas right around the
cores of other galaxies and on one side
it seemed to be moving away from us very
fast that would be the
the red shifted uh uh gas and on the
other side of the center of
those galaxies we'd see stuff that
appeared to be moving toward us very
fast
blue shifted light and so you can tell
that the material is orbiting very fast
and from that calculate that the only
thing that would create orbits that fast
would be a lot of mass condensed in a
very small volume and the only thing
that answers that question
are supermassive black holes so now let
me ask you when you as you talk about
this process what
immediately comes to my mind is the
process
how long does something like this take
or
is it that you are doing mathematical
interpolation or making extrapolations
from a period of time that you're
looking at
the the uh information that you're
receiving how long was it what take
just the whole yeah the whole discovery
the discovery and observation okay the
whole deal
okay that's a good point from proposal
to publish paper right how long does
that take
well i have to say it all depends
so so an observation depending on what
you're doing like
i mentioned that deep field took several
days of observations
others if it's something bright if it's
just one pointing you can do it maybe in
an
hour or two but then you need to go
through some processing time for the
data comes down but it needs some data
processing
uh you know in that case usually we can
get images out if they're just simple
snapshots within a few days
wow but if you're doing scientific
analysis like you're
you're doing a proposal to answer some
question that requires
quite a lot of analysis maybe
comparisons with data from other
telescopes these kinds of things
that can take months or a year um
sometimes even years so
it just depends on the complexity of the
question that's being asked and
and that's being in the data how the
data are being used
and then you submit the paper it gets
peer reviewed okay
right then maybe they want adjustments
to it because you didn't
dot your eye or across your tee then you
do that satisfy
the the reviewer then it gets accepted
for publication then it gets scheduled
right and so that that adds a chunk of
time at the end there as well
but so now that makes me think of
another question i know we're short on
time but
what happens if somebody is looking for
something or
they say propose this and then the peer
review comes back and says no no no
but then you find something even bigger
has that ever happened
well first of all there are we don't
have time chuck oh okay we got to go to
break well i guess that is an answer
here's your answer we don't have time
all right uh
hubble 30th anniversary on star talk
when we return
we last left off with chuck in the
middle of the question
what happens if whatever issues the
first proposed
research paper confronts right they
they they discover something even better
right well the peer review says oh no
that's not the case and then they find
something that's like
whoa wait the peer reviewers or their
brothers both either one
anybody goes but they miss something
they miss something and then they go oh
my goodness i just okay
want to know if that ever happened like
i'm i have a thing for that
to like like radio karate like die cut
his eye and he goes wait i can see
whoa who knew like that i love you okay
you know
okay let me try to parse that
uh so again these observations typically
go through
two peer reviews one is to get the time
to use hubble in the first place so so
that means that
they generally had a pretty good idea of
why these observations would be useful
and then there's the second one when
they after they've done the analysis of
the data and they submit their analysis
to
the the professional journal of what
they think they found
and true enough the journals can
actually say
you know we don't actually think this is
this is right or profound and maybe
choose not to publish
it or but usually they do what's
interesting now
by then but what's interesting is that
that data that may have been used for
the initial proposers
purposes is now available for other
researchers to use and
as we discussed about the archive they
can pull that data and find something
that the original proposer didn't even
think of
to use with this data and that has
happened quite a lot
let me tell you why it becomes a whole
other research
and the reason is because hubble has
been around so long
30 years now of often taking sometimes
repeated observations of the same areas
in the sky for different purposes
we can now look back and see things that
have changed over time
which is very interesting in particular
in our solar system looking back
at images of let's say jupiter over time
year after year after year and then
starting to compare these images and
saying whoa
as we look back at this data that may be
even taken for different purposes
in earlier years but we can see trends
let's say that
big uh great red spot on
jupiter it's a big storm but as we look
over the decades
you know what its official term is no
jupiter's red spot
oh there you go right just so you know
just you can stay with the lingo
i don't want her to lose you yeah why
you guys got to get all fancy
i think it's we're trying to make it
clear the great red spot
is is there but it is however
it is shrinking as we look at these
images year after year after year
it's like whoa this storm is changing
it's changing in color
it's getting smaller we see new storms
cropping up
so this is one of the benefits of having
a telescope operating so long
and being able to look back in that
archive it data that
may have been taken for some other
purpose but then stringing it all
together
and we see how things have changed are
changing
over time did you uh find the monolith
in the red spot
uh if she can't she cannot all right
next question next question
uh none detectable oh okay she's not
authorized to go beyond that
exactly now i'm seeing a conspiracy all
right robert weaver from patreon wants
to know this
what is the most interesting unexplained
thing we have observed with hubble is
there something that astrophysicists are
still trying to work out love
that hubble who robert weaver
robert weaver way to go robert you're uh
you have impressed the rooms
robert that's a terrific question and uh
i
a couple of things come to mind um
hubble
is observing a lot of effects of what we
call
dark matter and so we can't really see
dark matter and we don't know what it is
it's a mystery but hubble can see where
it is because it's distributed pretty
heavily
in these clusters of galaxies we can see
the galaxies but we know there's a lot
more stuff in there because hubble sees
what's called lensing of light coming
from behind those clusters of galaxies
that's traveling through that cluster
and it gets distorted
it gets magnified and stretched out and
so
background galaxies look kind of strange
when they come through these regions
and we can because of that we can map
out where the dark matter is but it's
still a mystery as to
what it it actually is and even more
mysterious is something we call dark
energy because
this is a a surprise we
were looking uh at we've been for all
all of hubble's mission we've been
measuring very carefully the expansion
rate of the universe that was one of the
original goals of hubble
but just a few years ago wasn't that one
of the original reasons why it was named
hubble
well exactly so evan hubble himself
discovered the expanding universe
exactly so that if this telescope was
going to
go all in on that you might as well name
it after the guy who put it on the map
exactly so hubble was one of the first
goals of hubble was to measure better
the rate
of the expansion of the universe we
expected that as we were became
better able to look at more distant
galaxies which is looking back at time
and measuring the expansion rate at that
time and comparing it to the expansion
rate in the current epoch
that we would see that the expansion
rate of the universe has been slowing
down that was the expectation because
the
gravity basically is trying to pull
things together and
perhaps slow down this expansion the
surprise
in recent years was that by comparing
hubble observations with also
tel observations from good telescopes on
the ground
and looking at the difference between
the expansion rate in the distant
universe meaning far in the past
with the expansion rate in our current
epic
that the universe expansion rate has has
actually in recent
epochs meaning in recent billions of
years
been getting faster it's accelerating it
for it was first decelerating and now
it's accelerating
uh we don't know what's causing that
hubble's a big player in this in this
discovery it's not the only player but
it's a big player and so now this is a
whole new enterprise in astrophysics is
trying to understand
what is it that could be accelerating
the expansion of the universe we're
getting better with age that's all
all right attacking a billion years
you're looking
looking even better that's right that's
right look at that all right cool
man all right so let's go to cameron uh
kessler from facebook
says does hubble have any sufficient
technology
to keep up with the needs of today's
understanding of the universe
and will there ever be a telescope with
a 360 panoramic view like google street
maps
it's a pretty cool that's the measure of
the future
of cosmic discovery is will we have
a google cosmos maps like google street
maps
um i know the mars rovers do this
their pictures uh but would it make more
sense to have this sort of thing instead
of
falling back on the now this is get
thrown a little shade here
the excuse we have to look in the right
places
as they used to say in seti
i'm trying to understand the question is
it in other words is it let's look
everywhere
instead of in places we think we want to
find something exactly because we might
discover something we're not looking for
otherwise
basically what you're saying like google
maps like so it's just like i really
want to go to 359 main street but what's
that over there
oh my god that coffee shop looks pretty
okay
this is a very good question and we need
both because we want to be able to see
everything in the sky and we have survey
telescopes that are designed to do just
that
to have big fields of view and to survey
the entire sky
often for a particular reason so right
now for example we have the
tess satellite that's serving the sky
but looking specifically for stars that
may have
planetary systems around them in our
nearby neighborhood
is it fair to think of tess as a
follow-on to kepler i think so
yeah and tess get me through that uh the
transiting exoplanet survey satellite i
think i'm
i'm going to have to remind myself but
but anyway the hot the idea of tests
is to do just that survey transiting
evidence survey
telescope
there's a telescope being designed for
the ground the large synoptic survey
telescope the whole idea of this is to
do
the whole sky survey very frequently so
it's a good idea
however when you're doing that you're
not getting the precision
on small fields of view that you can get
with a telescope like hubble
so it depends on your the purposes at
large if you really want
a high angular resolution precision
high sensitivity observation of
something
that's a different goal than doing a
whole sky survey and we sort of need
both of that so the best way this works
is if you're doing whole sky surveys and
then if you find something that you'd
really like
more detail about then you hone in with
some other telescope
to do that hubble is really not good for
these whole sky
surveys um it's much better for
pointing and getting much higher angular
resolution
my favorite example this is the orion
nebula i love the orion region of the
sky
it's a very famous constellation um i
did my own doctoral research on
on star formation in this region of the
sky isn't the closest star-forming
region to us
it's the closest region of massive star
formation so stars bigger than our sun
but they light up these massive stars
once they form they
they're so powerful they ionize the
surrounding gas so you get these
beautiful
nebulae so the orion nebula is famous
hubble
can peer into that was born in the orion
nebula
you know maybe i was
she's a spirit energy of the orion
nebula possible i wasn't
told but maybe you know you never
how would you know right yeah yeah told
i was born in arkansas but you know
listen in this current climate let's go
with the arkansas
anyway i i love the the hubble image of
the orion nebula because it does give
you that
great detail you can see massive stars
you can see the colors but you don't get
the big
field of view that you can get with
other telescopes
that's great gotcha next all right here
we go um
this is huldwig at thunder o
storm on twitter and he says or
she says uh or they say if i want to be
correct oh this person says
it's possible to get through this jack
you know it's just that once i start
thinking about it i'm like well that
can't be right well that's not right
what are the projects that you think
will be
the most important for this
current decade so we're in the 20s now
what's going to happen between 20
and 30 that is the would this be what
hubble would be able to contribute in
this decade or is that more in general
they just say what are the projects i
mean of course they're talking about
telescopes
all right but they just say what are the
projects well that's a terrific question
and um hubble is poised to be a
major player in these astrophysics
discoveries in the coming decade
so one of them i've already mentioned is
kind of getting a better
grip on this idea that the universe is
expanding at an accelerating rate
um how's that why is that and how is
that working so
ordered that exactly and so uh
telescopes like hubble will be working
in concert with other observatories
the wide field infrared space telescope
or wfirst is a
telescope idea that's being developed
and
right now that will be a large again one
of these big fields of view that can
kind of
give us a better sense of how galaxies
are distributed and how they've been
become distributed over time and that's
related to dark matter and dark energy
just remind me
wasn't wfirst a retooled decommissioned
military telescope
right we took a telescope that had
another purpose and now we're
re-re-envisioning
it uh to do this kind of stud big
big surveys of in in the infrared which
helped reduce the cost
ultimately um it that was the idea
although sometimes
it smells like a no retooling things has
its own complications
but it is it is going to be a terrific
telescope
um i i was in the middle time at spy
telescopes
the name of the game i think for the
coming decade is
is complementary cooperative work let me
tell you one of my favorites
is that hubble is being used in
complement with
probes that we're sending out to other
planets planets in our solar system
and we get much more information this
way than we would by just hubble alone
or just the probe alone for
example the juno probe that's at jupiter
right now
is getting all kinds of information
about jupiter's magnetic field and
gravitational field
and hubble is back here orbiting the
earth looking at jupiter
and hubble has the unique ability to see
the ultraviolet light coming from the
auroras the the magnetic poles of
jupiter
and those are dancing around relevant to
what's happening with the magnetic
fields around jupiter that juno is
measuring in situ there so this
cooperative work gives us a lot better
understanding
of these magnetic fields and what what's
happening
in jupiter and even its moons than we
could it's not it's not an after the
fact
conjoining of data it's an in situ yes
that is beautiful i love that
right we're doing things cooperatively
with hubble
uh another example in just the recent
past was
when the new horizons probe um
went uh past pluto but pluto goes
unmentioned here we don't
oh well you know pluto is still there
and it's doing fine
right so and in fact
just because you're not taking pluto's
calls neil
doesn't mean okay i'll make an exception
i'll make an exception okay
pluto is beautiful and hubble was used
as new horizons was on its way out there
hubble was used to
find other undiscovered moons around
pluto and to help new horizons help us
chart a good course for new horizons and
even to help new horizons to know what
objects to look at beyond
pluto so these are things that i think
are examples of how
hubble and other telescopes are going to
be
used cooper cooperatively in the coming
years to give us a lot more information
than we could from any observatory alone
wasn't there also a mission i have a
memory where there was a probe
to an asteroid where it
dropped a a a a
projectile which would then kick up
asteroid dust
and then collect no with in a direction
and an azimuth and an angle so that was
it hubble that would then be able to see
through the dust and get a spectrum
well that was the idea yes so so it was
it kicked up dust it was observed by
quite a few telescopes
quite a few telescopes and i would have
to uh you know to look into the details
of what was found but i thought that was
a really nifty idea so it's another
example of a
i'll do this and then you can do that
yeah yeah yeah cosmic collaboration yeah
by the way what a brilliant idea yeah to
drop a projectile and
kick up the dust and then look through
it look through it with with
ground-based telescopes or space-based
telescopes
yeah i gotta say you guys are really
smart
wow you guys are really smart man you
nasa people
it's amazing what you do so we gotta
wind this this section
could chuck if i did not bring in a huge
topic of interest for the coming decade
which is the whole topic of exoplanets
and this is where telescopes will be
working very cooperatively
uh we didn't even know back when i was
in graduate school if there were planets
orbiting other stars
stars other than our sun now because of
telescopes on the ground and telescopes
like kepler in space we know of
thousands
of star systems that have planets and so
now we can presume that most stars have
at least one planet
hubble will be being used in the coming
decade to do more
analysis of the atmospheres of these
exoplanets
complementing work from telescopes like
tess that's looking around for nearby
systems that have planets
and finds the system then there's the
handoff to hubble
to analyze the system yes and in other
telescopes too also the james webb space
telescope that will be launched in 2021
will be looking at exoplanetary systems
in the infrared part of the spectrum and
that will complement hubble's
observations of these exoplanetary
systems hubble can see a little in the
infrared but mostly in visible and
ultraviolet light
and so we'll be getting this wonderful
suite of information
by using hubble and complement with
other telescopes about
the nature of exoplanets
[Music]
excellent just think about it first you
got to know that it exists right
then you have that catalog and now you
go in with a whole other layer of
questions
right yes and then that might open other
questions you didn't even know to ask
at the previous round so you could take
this yeah yeah now you're saying well i
wouldn't now want to look at the
atmosphere of the planet
you're not happy just knowing there's a
planet there exactly when there was a
day when that was a banner headline
there's a planet there right right so
what a luxury to even
have that ability to make that
measurement exactly we gotta take a
break
okay when we come back we'll finish out
our 30th anniversary
cosmic queries on star talk
welcome back to star talk cosmic queries
hubble 30th anniversary edition with
jennifer wiseman
from the goddard space flight center
in greenbelt maryland greenbelt maryland
right outside of dc i've been there it's
a huge campus
i mean it's it's it's and it's like it's
got
engineers and scientists working in
harmony nice
absolutely that's that's as as jets and
sharks living in chats
look at that
crazy boys
i just saw a website story on broadway
yeah the the revival yeah the new one
yeah yeah
what are we talking about the telescopes
are the hub
sorry and then goddard campus so
chuck we got more questions here we go
um this is from louis
um i'm sorry the force
choked podcast okay i don't know what
that is but
from instagram hey neil and jennifer
what is the plan for hubble
as its final photo and when will that be
what's the lifespan of hubble how long
how long can this go on well that's a
great question
you know hubble was was launched back in
1990 from the space shuttle and it was
designed to be
continually replenished with the space
shuttle missions which we did
for for a lot longer than we originally
expected uh so we're not servicing it
anymore because the space shuttle
program is is over we're now building a
new future
spacecraft um yes exactly
so we've got what we've got with hubble
but hubble's working very well the last
astronaut servicing mission we did back
in 2009 was very successful and they've
left the telescope the astronauts went
up and put in some new science
instruments and repaired some other
instruments
and some and some other equipment on the
telescope it's a satellite
orbiting the earth and hubble is doing
very well right now
okay do they leave graffiti on it
because they're the last ones there like
susie was here uh if they did they
didn't tell me yeah all right all right
right but
that question i know i know i just see
her getting a little disturbed it was
really a
joke question it was a joke and if they
did they did not tell me
that i swear i will give them such a
look i want you to know
out there that i did not have that look
at all
i have too late
i will tell you that one of the
astronauts john grunsfeld who is an
astronomer himself
brought with him and a friend of star
talk he's been on several times
yeah yeah he brought with him a model of
galileo's telescope
and so up there on the space shuttle
during the last servicing mission
we had this marvelous juxtaposition of
this model of galileo's telescope from
400 years ago
first telescope and out the window of
the cockpit of the shuttle you could see
the hubble space telescope and so it was
just a wonderful
visual of how the progress of of
engineering and curiosity and optics all
work together to give us a brand new
understanding
of the universe exactly yeah you can be
as curious as all get out oh well
if nobody's paying for your ideas right
yeah you just just go back to the case
that's some great ideas
but you have to have the ideas to get
people to donate the money so
it's all works together all right well
speaking of that let me i didn't quite
answer your question so hubble is um
is working very well and so we don't
really have an end date of hubble in
mind
the kind of stated nasa position now is
as long as hubble is being
scientifically productive
we'll keep operating it and it looks
like just from looking at the health of
the gyroscopes and the batteries and the
science instruments that we'll be able
to get good science from hubble for
probably through the end of this decade
and maybe even beyond
not bad and and that's great because we
want it to be
operating while other telescopes are
also operating with complementary
capabilities
the james webb space telescope should
launch in 2021
and it will be a fabulous space
telescope
tuned into infrared wavelengths of light
right and so in the infrared you can
appear at galaxies that are coming
they're very distant in space and time
their light is getting red-shifted as it
travels through
expanding space to get to us and hubble
can't see
that far into the infrared spectrum of
light so
hubble can see very distant galaxies but
the web will see
galaxies even a little bit farther back
in space and time
we're going to emphasize something you
just said because i it's remarkable to
me yeah
all right so we are seeing infrared
light from galaxies
in the early universe who
in the early universe were emitting
visible light right
okay
right over to the infrared part that the
january telescope is
tuned to see that's nice right so we're
folding in that knowledge of the
universe
right to nab those galaxies right when
they're being born right i i like to put
it this way the universe we think
at least the universe that that we know
and love
started about 13.8 billion years ago
okay
and hubble is seeing all the way back
right now to
baby galaxies from within that first
point eight
of the 13.8 billion year history of the
universe
and the web we'll see even closer to the
beginning of the universe within a few
hundred million years of the beginning
of the you can see basically the cradle
of creation
infant galaxies with with almost little
games in the universe when it's crowning
that's amazing well it's amazing
it's just like oh my god the baby is
coming in a second
truck this is a little too graphic
it's not it's let's think a little later
let's think toddlers okay
okay because what these telescopes are
seeing are the first
after the first gas formed from the
first atoms which
first from the form from the first
subatomic particles you finally get
enough gas to form stars
and these stars and gas coalitions if
you will are what we call the first
proto galaxies
and that's as far back that's what the
web telescope will be we'll be seeing
and over time these these little baby
galaxies began to merge
together and form bigger galaxies and
these grew over cosmic time into the
galaxies we know and love
today like our own milky way which is
the product of several mergers over time
right
and has there been any recent collisions
that we have seen of galaxies well of
course it takes a long time for galaxies
to actually merge but hubble
actually that's one of the one of the
wonderful discoveries of the hubble
space telescope is
that merging is common and was more
common in
in the early universe so with hubble
we've looked out into distant space
looking back
in time and we've seen quite a few cases
where galaxies are either in the process
of merging
or they've already merged and that
merging process creates distortions in
the shapes of these galaxies because of
the
tidal pulls and the gravitational pulls
and it's quite interesting we believe
that our own milky way
is set to merge with our nearest
neighbor big
spiral grand spiral the andromeda
and we're on a head-on collision course
that's something hubble helped us uh
find a few years ago
so the night sky was going to look a lot
different in a few billion years
but it won't be for quite a long quite
some time billions of years
staying right there with the uh with
with the future here
um uh team fort site observatory
wants to know this hi neil jennifer
chuck uh
would it be possible if nasa ends
funding for hubble or
um it comes to its regular end someone
like
uh elon musk could buy the rights to the
scope and send his own repair missions
thereby
now owning a telescope good question
because we are seeing that right we are
seeing why we are seeing the
commercialization of space we are seeing
more
uh collaboration between the public and
private sector
with respect to missions to space so
what what's the feasibility of this
is it for sale yeah it is not for sale
yet um if you're a billionaire say
everything's for sale
exactly the current plan is we'll
operate hubble for as many years as it
is scientifically productive and then
when it's not
um no longer providing a good science
um it will cease to function
eventually we'll need to either push the
satellite itself either to a higher
orbit we call it a parking orbit or or
else help direct it safely into the
ocean um pacific ocean yeah well i don't
know exactly where
um but uh as for private company
involvement we don't have any official
plans for that right now but let me tell
you there's a lot of energetic
discussions out there so
uh you know stay tuned for that i love
that idea
if if it's hubble's we're gonna plunk
hubble in the pacific
or someone can buy it i think let
somebody buy it right and continue to
receive information let me let me
add this though astronomers think about
this very hard all the time what's the
best kind of facility to have to do the
kinds of astrophysics we want to do
and there comes a point such as came the
point with my own car
recently where you have to decide is it
worth it to put a lot of money into
continuing to refurbish something that's
decades old
as they call it nickel and diming
exactly or is it better to build
something fresh using newer technology
so
you know hubble's not in that situation
we hope hubble will be operating for
for much of the next decade and beyond
but at some point
the decision will need to be made as to
whether the kinds of capabilities that
hubble
does could be better done with a new
telescope and in fact there's some
wonderful
concepts being developed right now for
hubble follow-ons
fantastic all right all right neil told
me did we make this
last one right for you for you because
this is a personal question just
for you doctor um and this is from
brett sharra and brett shaw from
instagram says
what is your favorite hubble
discovery by the way i'm a huge fan
thanks for all
that you do so this is somebody who
follows you
and wants to know what is your favorite
hubble
anything uh i'll slip into my favorite
hubble
discovery it doesn't sound flashy but is
actually the
looking at things like the ultra deep
field and finding out that galaxies
themselves
change in amazing ways over billions of
years and hubble being the time machine
that it is we can actually map out by
looking at distant galaxies and
comparing them to nearby ones how
they've changed so this ultra deep field
is even deeper than the original concept
of deep field that's right
once once they got the deep field
swagger
right it's like let's do this again
right yeah exactly
okay let's get a deeper field and then
one one image that i just love it's it's
nothing
special if you will but it's just a
beautiful galaxy it doesn't have a
beautiful name ngc 1309
i just think is a gorgeous spiral so
those of you listening to this go out
and google
ngc 1309 hubble and you'll see a
beautiful spiral with some interesting
galaxies in the background
if you call it on your phone ngc 1409
it'll answer
and then there's beautiful nebulae i'm
holding one now ngc
you're holding a picture i'm holding a
picture of one yes
actually uh it was on a cat's collar
ngc 3603 3603
ngc 3603 so if someone googles that
they'll go to this image on yeah
in the name you'll see this cluster of
newly formed stars surrounded by
beautiful ionized gas a kind of purplish
nebula
and to me this just shows great beauty
in the universe
and how our telescopes are enabling us
to see these kinds of beautiful
active regions that we haven't been able
to see in such detail before in human
history
and this inspires all kinds of things
even beyond science
art science philosophy uh all kinds of
things are inspired by the observations
we can do with hubble
uh and other telescopes today and i'm
grateful for that so
thank you for your comments yeah i just
looked up ngc
1309 and apple owes you guys some money
why because this is what comes up on my
computer that's the hubble image and the
galaxy no it's it's it's not uh it's
it they don't owe any money because all
of our images are
freely available to anyone and so uh you
don't already paid for it they pay
we pay our tax dollars tax money paid oh
in that case apple owes me some money
that's right
uh you can fight that out with them yes
okay
are we gonna land this plane all right
uh so jennifer you have any just
concluding
reflective thoughts beyond what you have
the
reflective thoughts you've already
shared i i think that um
the hubble space telescope has shown how
we can use as human humanity we can use
technology to do something that not only
enhances
our scientific understanding of nature
and
but also gives us a sense of unity there
are people all over the world from every
nation that are excited about the hubble
space telescope and what we're seeing
and it gives us i think i hope a sense
of unity as
citizens of earth that were part of a
magnificent universe
an inspiring universe something to look
up at and be inspired by
and to keep our sights our spirits high
um i think
astronomy inspires all kinds of positive
positive um and when that asteroid
deeper
deeper thoughts of beauty and and
philosophy
and in theology and art and music and
all of these things are part of what it
means to be human
so uh keep looking up i'd say
somebody
jennifer you just took us out that was
jennifer wiseman
ending star talk for me
all right we'll catch you on the next
[Applause]
round
[Music]